jared leto quite the Joker isn't it J
Gregory is Alba here jab eco egg jovica
yeah beak away jab eco a say it three
times in the mirror they'll come out and
kill you Jared Leto apparently he's he's
not too happy with what happened with
Suicide Squad as all of you know
according to the fan report in Batman
news Jared Leto was very honest about
the film this weekend his disappointment
and what he's learned at the theatrical
cut yeah he's still not seen the film
feeling sort of tricked into being a
part of something that hasn't been
pitched to him very differently thinking
it would have been more artistic than
what it became feeling overwhelmed by
the hate regarding the look in choices
and he also didn't mentioned how he felt
he shot enough Joker scenes I could have
made a whole movie
yeah and how he shouldn't be rock
climbing this is dangerous and against
his contract but he just keeps showing
that he's gonna keep rock climbing the
whole letter b/w Donna termination they
could sue him for that they could sue
him for that however I think DC and
Warner Brothers are kinda used to people
hating on them it's only a matter of
time until one of their own turns
against he's got [ __ ] money look at
me
Jared Leto he's got [ __ ] he's like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] him doing Joker
wasn't for the money it was for the
opportunity to do a cool role and that's
why I think Jerry Leto can totally get
away with this is this is only
increasing his fans wanting to see more
of him as the Joker like wishing they
could just have seen the scenes that
Jared Leto like really feels should have
been in the cut according to this
article that cut out like 99% of what
you shop he only has about like five to
ten minutes ten minutes maybe and
suicide spawn you know this is
everything just a quick cut to him you
don't get time to get to know his Joker
you could feel there's probably a great
performance that if I could just see it
it makes him feel like an afterthought
yeah like I kind of need to give a [ __ ]
that he was in the movie he felt kind of
pointless to a lot of the story he felt
just over all of this film shouldn't
happen
pg-13 right it's really cool to hear
like one of the stars of the movie say
that I'm really happy that Jared Leto is
actually like we've never had this
happen with the Joker before Jack
Nicholson especially at the time when he
played the Joker he really doesn't do
interviews
they're very rare where he'll do an
interview and he didn't really start
talking about his portrayal of the Joker
till way down the road like many years
have gone by and then Heath Ledger he
passed away before the Dark Knight came
out and this it's like all we wanted was
I wanted to see more than what was in
the trailer but like that just all we
wanted like if they release like a joke
or cut like Suicide Squad where they
include all of it
I would absolutely watch it I buy it
right away in a heartbeat and it would
suck if they released all that and
everyone was like that was the worst
joke I've ever seen
do you think it's possible that given
how much footage they've shot that they
could go and release a joker solo film
that's money that they could be making
he is the Joker he's one of the stars of
Suicide Squad it's supposed to be an
integral part to a lot of the other
upcoming DC films especially the Batman
stories of course the fact that the star
is actually strengthening his fans
desires to see more of him as a Joker by
hating the studio I don't think will end
in his termination of his contract I
feel like this is just gonna help sell
more tickets down the road
this has helped solidified him to get
more it's a different story but x-men
origins Wolverine had a lot of hate and
stuck [ __ ] and but then Ryan Reynolds
had a few minutes in it but people
thought like he was great as Wade Wilson
and that he should play Deadpool and
then the fans really out spoke against
Fox and everything and they got their
wish eventually and I feel like there's
something kind of similar happening here
where Jared Leto's fans are gonna like
pretty much whatever project he's in
next where he's really featured the show
they're gonna make sure he's in the
[ __ ] movie cuz I don't think fans are
gonna be happy if they if they if they
fire him this is awesome what up this is
unprecedented never have we seen a star
completely talk [ __ ] about a studio and
that's just propelling offense
especially like a weed after the movie
yeah this is making fans cry out for him
to play the role again or show
his role as the Joker but you're making
a connection to x-men origins there and
I don't think that connection is there
like the the reason why we got Deadpool
was because Ryan Reynolds put out that
that leaked footage had nothing to do
with xmin origins no but the whole
reason that they even shot footage was
because the fans wanted it the fan turn
wanted him to be Deadpool okay
I've said it's not I won't argue with
you Greg I get I get it you want to be
right that's cool this has gotta me to
the point where I'm like they should
just do a joker movie like if some Joker
movie like instead of him just being the
villain it's at the point where Jared
Leto is like feels so robbed they could
shoot some like movie down the road
where it's just about the joke I heard
The Killing Joke was awful by the way
the cartoon well maybe she stopped just
hearing the peoples of pain so go watch
know what my point of bringing that up
and I don't really like them I heard it
also [ __ ] with the source material a
little bit too much but what I'm getting
it is if they've already got footage
that they've shot that they could
potentially like or theoretically make a
film out of they could make money back
and appease the fans see a different
studio different comic book but for Days
of Future past they made a rogue cut
yeah and it wasn't really a road cut
it's just like oh this is the version
where we have the few minutes a rogue in
the parody did you know she got paid
like three million dollars well she and
she was cut from the film that's awesome
let's go got our own special DVD really
but you know one thing that people that
I saw there's a post I didn't finish my
point of it do you listen when I talk so
I'm saying they could do right with
doing a Suicide Squad Joker cut and
actually give us like a [ __ ] ton of
Joker scenes as opposed to of this is
just a few more minutes of the Joker
point done I think it should just be a
joker movie I don't think that it should
be a Suicide Squad film it should be
because according to Leto
there is enough footage to make a Joker
movie it's gonna feel I don't know I
think he was just talking about the fact
that there's so much footage but that
doesn't mean it's enough to make it into
a go he
story that's why you have to go back and
do some reshoots to pad it out
I think they should reshoot bits to make
a Joker exclusive filthy I wouldn't go I
don't think the students would ever do
that for like an actual theater release
maybe maybe I like one night I don't
know a like Kill Bill where it was
supposed to be one movie and they split
it into two different films I don't see
why you can't do the same thing with
this it's a it's different we've never
seen it happen before
that doesn't mean it can't be done but
what you're talking about is more the
more likely scenario where it's just an
extended edition one counter-argument
that I've heard against letõs at
frustrations is that you got paid dude
you got paid to do your job you were
paid no shut up go away I don't like
that argument he did what he came to
give you this performance you you're
like okay
imagine this all right you get cast as
the Joker you put your life's work in
the Joker so people it's because people
are gonna see your performance as the
Joker all these stories started coming
out generally don't let it was promoting
the [ __ ] out of this movie yeah and then
the movie comes out and you find out
yeah but that's his job as an actor
where he's paid to be part of the
promotion look you're just playing
devil's advocate man like if that
happened to you you damn right I be
pissed I but the thing is he did his job
that was your shirt unless you are a
producer on the film or you're in the
editing room that's par for the course
man like you are subject to the whims of
what the producers say okay we'll make a
WB and a Jared Leto list and WB you can
have that one and then will you look at
the roof you're looking at it from an
artistic standpoint right but I'm seeing
even the business side of it I think one
of brothers if they just look at what
letõs talking about they can make their
money back by having a whole other joker
film that's all some people would
totally watch it yeah yeah people what I
just don't feel like WB's the kind of
studio to be like you know what it's a
risky choice let's try it I don't see
what the risk is I bet you yeah it's
already shot and stuff yeah they spent
so much money on the goddamn soundtrack
to Suicide Squad I'm sure that the cost
to make us exclusive Joker film would be
you know a drop in the back sure that's
no more to think about yeah I don't like
that he's rock climbing while he's
shooting I personally disagree that rock
climbing while he's shooting he's not
shooting anything right now but he's
still because he might shoot something
later yeah I completely disagree really
upset over the fact that his personal
life choice to go rock life yeah because
that's just risky yo I am a balance I'm
a happy medium yo like him him doing
this is just like Harrison Ford flying
that plane and crashing it when we all
thought that Harrison Ford was gonna be
an episode P I just think that's stupid
to take chances with your life 15-7 be
new errors and four toes in episode 7 we
didn't know he was dying in episode 7 we
thought he might be in episode 8 still
so him taking chances with his life was
just obnoxious that's why I find this to
be obnoxious like don't take chances
with your life when there's a
possibility you might still be in this
movie you're gonna [ __ ] up so much money
there and make the it studios to go find
someone to replace you yeah that's a
good business important of you from an
artistic point of view I feel like that
he's that kind of actor that needs to
constantly experience and constantly do
what he loves doing and feel that way
when he does his job he does a great job
you can't cause him to repress what he
wants to feel and do an experience
bottom line what I love interesting
about this is the whole idea like people
speculate like is he gonna get fired I
really don't think that's gonna happen
if anything this is just gonna make the
extended cut or whatever come out and
this is gonna make the next film where
he's like in the trailer it's gonna plug
in to make it a more rewarding time
they're gonna give him promises to what
she'll have to return I think he'll
fight his way out of the contract if
they don't honor his desires what wasn't
one of her was just given you know one
of those automated rock climbing things
you can climb in his backyard it's the
same thing huh that's way better it's
safer he'll fall on grass instead of a
thousand is about the experience of
doing that
give him VR goggles give him oculus
rifts that he can feel like he's
climbing [ __ ] not the same thing it's
about reality have you seen someone like
feel like they're falling when they
using the oculus rift they scream their
heads off because they think they're
actually falling it controls your senses
yeah but I think in real life you're
smarter additionally on Facebook the
other day there Hawk ulis rift is
helping people to learn how to walk
again people who
were formerly paralyzed and now we're
getting feeling in their feet because
their brain is learning what it's like
to walk again oculus rift is the real
[ __ ] yo he could just do off those rip
instead of taking chances with his life
like that that's all I'm saying
you can disagree with me [ __ ] I just
think it's dumb don't take chances with
you alive that's it subscribe to
Gregory's channel and subscribe to javi
Kawai I still like you Jared Leto